[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout
if you're joining for the first time i'm
rachel and it's great to meet you
if you've been here before you've heard
this deal a bunch of times before
but if this is your first hangout this
is an open space for the whole data
science community to connect and chat
about data science leadership
questions you're facing and
what's really going on in the world of
data science
so the sessions are recorded and shared
to the our studio youtube as well as the
data science hangout site so you can
always go back and re-watch and find
helpful resources too
i'll say it up front as well because i
always forget we do have a linkedin
group as well for the hangout so if you
ever want to connect with people there
or continue a certain discussion
you can use that too and
i'll put it into the chat in just a
moment
we always want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
so there's three ways that you can ask
questions today all this is audience led
you can jump in by raising your hand on
zoom you can put questions into the zoom
chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to it if you want me to read it out
loud
or else i could just call on you to
introduce yourself and add some context
and then also we have the slido link
where you can ask questions anonymously
too
and i see tyler just shared that in the
chat thank you
i like to reiterate we love to hear from
everyone regardless of your level of
experience or the area of work um as
well
but with all that today i'm so happy to
be joined by my co-host and i'll say
so excited that i even announced on
twitter a day ahead that i thought
yesterday was thursday
but so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today tanya cashierelli
tanya is ceo and founder of tcb
analytics
and tanya i'd like to kick these off
with just having you introduce yourself
and sharing a little bit about the work
that you do
sure yeah um
yeah i got nervous i was like oh no is
it wednesday instead of thursday
but um no i'm always on days yeah
it's been one of those weeks um i'm
tanya i uh
let's say the short version i
got my career started um
i do a major in computer science and
biology so i started in the
bioinformatics world so
um probably
unsurprisingly that's how i got started
using r uh it was about 2005 or so
believe it or not and um i was working
at a
children's hospital informatics program
for a bunch of really smart phds and had
no clue what r is he
told me go home this summer and read
about r so i actually
printed like the entirety of the crayon
documentation and took it home and
thought oh man this is like really i
thought it was just i was in over my
head but um
yeah i had some really great mentors and
i learned a lot and then i worked in
biotech for a few years um
a bunch of startups and then i did some
non-healthcare stuff
a telecom startup
found myself back in healthcare at
biogen which is a big my first big
company that i worked at and
always knew i wanted to consult and kind
of do stuff on the side so i was doing
that
and
only lasted there nine months big
company just like wasn't for me
even though i learned a lot and had a
great time i met a lot of cool people
and i started tcp analytics in
2015 or so and we have clients kind of
all industries
pharma
we do we work with um financial trading
companies uh we worked with the
department of defense and we did some
pretty cool ai machine learning stuff uh
for the army so really all over the map
and just having fun because we get to
kind of pick and choose our projects and
i get to work with friends so
hopefully that was a short short answer
that's awesome
well um we're waiting for questions to
come in from everyone i'm curious what's
something you're most excited about
in data science in the next year so
yeah you know i started i was thinking
about like what tools and stuff are
exciting but i don't think it's tooling
or anything like that it's um
it's really that it's becoming more
widespread and known and i feel like
it's getting evangelized more and the
more people i talk to
people a lot of you have probably had
this experience before like what the
heck is data science i have no idea what
you're talking about and usually i use
the sports example because everyone kind
of knows the movie moneyball and um
fantasy sports and i just think people
are starting to get it more um and
obviously that's good for us and helpful
for us
so
it's a simple answer but yeah i think
i'm just excited that more and more
people are just getting it like
i thought years ago that ceos at every
company should be familiar enough with
data and the basics of data analysis the
same way that they were expected to be
familiar with email like 30 years ago
everyone started using email i think
data is getting to that same point
definitely i see libby you asked the
question in the chat if you want to jump
in
sure i was wondering what about your
experience made you decide that the big
company was not for you whether that was
like a
you know wanting a bigger variety of
projects or there were id barriers or
different stuff like that
yeah um
i think the pace at which things moved
now at the time i was very burnt out
from working at startups so i kind of
liked like
breathing a little bit um
and
i think just a lot of politics to have
to go through you know trying to do
seemingly simple tasks it just was like
a lot of bureaucracy so
you kind of felt like you had your hands
tied in a lot of situations um that said
there were really good parts about it
too um just learning how to navigate
those those big companies and um the
people that i met uh
yeah i'd say it was probably just i felt
like i couldn't really get much done or
push the needle in certain certain ways
that i could in a in a startup yeah lots
of red tape exactly
i see connor you just asked the question
as well if you want to jump in next
hi tanya um i i work here at our studio
with our our consulting customers so i
would love to understand what youview is
like the biggest challenges for data
analytics consulting in 2022 or just in
general
hmm biggest challenges it's always
people
it's never art it does everything uh i
can make our and shiny do anything but
the p it comes down to i think um
i could tell when a client kind of knows
exactly what they want and most of our
our prospects and customers come to us
saying we know we need this we love
shiny we want to uh do things with shiny
and data but i think the hardest part is
getting people to understand why they're
doing what they're doing like there's so
many times where people just want to put
all the data into a data lake or
um let's join all these tables and and
i'm like why
so i'm always asking well what are you
trying what questions are you trying to
answer um and more importantly what
action will be taken and this sounds
probably like a trope to everyone on
this call but it's amazing how many
people and clients just they want to
check a box or they want to do the fun
data thing but they don't have any
uh
valuable business reasons for doing it
um so that's a hard thing um and then
another thing it's always scoping um i
feel like with data products it's much
different from like like a web
application
um because there's so many possibilities
like
as we're building things we constantly
run into situations and scenarios we
could not have predicted until we start
building it um so that's always tough
but we try to mitigate that by doing
either like retainer-based contracts or
being really conservative with the fixed
price and really scoping it out well
thank you
yeah and i noticed someone noticed my
turntables i used to dj in college back
when i was still cool in boston and i
actually i busted them back out during
the pandemic so
that's what that is
i think you know
the third data science leader slash dj
though really oh who are the other i
gotta know who the other ones are yeah
tanya it's uh funny this is javier um
there's another
person here who lives in southern
california sepp i don't know if he's on
this meet-up today
um he's involved with the so-caller
users group but we've known each other
for a few years and only this year
realized we were both dj's so we got got
together a few months ago and had a
little garage dj session it was fun
oh that's awesome well if you're not in
florida you'll have to let me know yeah
hey tanya i did have a quick question
for you um
you talked about making sure sort of
your statement of works are very clear
and concise and that
you know you try and price project base
how do you
i don't think the problem is data
science related necessarily but how do
you manage scope creep
it's tough um
yeah cause
i mean there's there's times where you
give a little and you know
you know show of good faith where things
are actually easy to do and you do it as
like all right like we'll do this one
thing but then that can be a slippery
slope and they think that now we can ask
for all the things so
um
it comes down to i think if you can
itemize everything um you know whether
it's in github issues or just jira
anywhere and then um really prioritize
that list so i find it's really hard to
do in a phase one because you're
learning so much so we try to we try to
estimate in like an exploratory uh
sometimes one month long even to
properly scope and that always you know
it's never perfect but i find for the
second phase and we just did this with a
project
we know a lot more and they started
asking for so many things we kept a
backlog
and then we have our consultants go in
and estimate and we always
pretty much i wouldn't say double but
we add some padding on to that for
uncertainties and then you just go back
to the client and say look you could
purchase you know block of hours 50
hours 100 hours but here's the list and
now you put the onus on them to
prioritize and say okay well we
definitely want this and this and even
on top of that i typically recommend
another block of miscellaneous hours for
like unknowns that come up um and that
allows you to at least like quantify it
because it becomes very like hand wavy
if you don't if you don't have that um
and if you can't back it into the money
or the cost
it's tough so i find fixed price it can
go either way it can it can really bite
you if it's not scoped well or you can
you can actually make some good margins
on it
so we try to balance that
with every project and i've just learned
more and more over the years of doing it
it really just has taken a lot of trial
and error and i've messed up for sure
and learned lessons from it
thank you
i know and one of the answers
just before this you said like the
hardest thing is people and like having
those conversations with people and they
just want to put a bunch of data into
data a data lake
how do you approach those conversations
yeah um
so one thing i like to do
is
again i always say i try to say like
what
what are people gonna pay for like what
are you building that your clients
actually will put money towards
um number two is again what will they do
with this information can they take
action from it but an example i can
think of
is like when you log into e-trade or
vanguard and you look at your stocks and
it says that you've got a you know
100 gain on this stock well what is that
what do i want to do about that i want
to sell it so typically there's a sell
button like right there you never have
to like look and browse through five
more pages to get to the sell button
um
no porch appeared
um
so i think that's that's a couple
questions i try to ask consistently is
you know what's the
what will your clients pay for and what
what decisions are they trying to make
and then i'll do that same exercise with
the people that are really like driving
product management um
for the data analysis so we'll actually
sit with a mock-up uh balsamic or you
know name your favorite mock-up tool and
we'll talk through it and we'll lay it
out and it's amazing the questions that
come up and once people start thinking
about it and seeing it and they think oh
yeah actually we need a filter here
because i didn't think that you know the
date range would matter and uh we need a
minimum threshold filter because we have
so few data points in this state
but those are things that i learn as i
build things in shiny to be honest um
just building it and showing it uh
yeah
that's great
darren i i see you have kind of a
follow-up to this question as well you
want to jump in yeah thanks rachel um
yeah javier you kind of
asked my question and i had a follow-up
to that um based on tony's response so
um
i've had a lot of experiences when
working with other clients in previous
jobs where they tell me
i know what i want i know what i don't
want
but i don't know what i want and so i'm
kind of
curious if you had those similar
experiences and how you manage those
expectations while also delivering a
product that they don't really know what
they want
that's like kind of where the art comes
in i think is um
and also getting the right people
involved on the client side um
so i try to like if there's a subject
matter expert um i always try to work
with them or if there's someone that i
know is a decision maker
um
because yeah it can be tough um
trying to think of another example
um
you know they'll
i think it's it's important not to also
rush to building something there's
definitely rapid prototyping but then
there's like well let's actually take a
minute and think uh i try to like list
out all the most common questions and
use cases and then also understand who
are the end users because this is a cmo
using it versus like a data analyst
one's going to be a very exploratory
design or dashboard and another one's
going to be like explanatory very simple
high level kpis maybe some drill downs
right
so yeah it's tough it really comes back
to having those conversations kind of
repeatedly over and over until it starts
to click
um but it's it's one of the hardest
things we have to deal with um but then
again i get clients that come in and
just they know
and they start building it and they're
like this is great
i hope that answers the question but it
yeah it's uh thank you it's not an easy
thing to navigate for sure uh that's why
i like the shiny prototyping actually
because you can kind of iterate until
they say okay this is right
versus like a full software build that
can take months
and then you're kind of stuck with this
big like
react thing and custom d3 and it's not
the right thing
see
javier or you're commenting maybe to
another question in the the chat too
um but mark i see you have a question
there as well do you want to jump in
yeah sure can you hear me
yeah it was a follow-up to
darren's question um
and i'm just i'm thinking from my own
experience i'm not in uh
uh you know i don't have external
clients to all internal for the company
i work for but
um
have you ever had a scenario where
up front you know your client is very
clear about what it is that they want um
kind of the inputs and outputs and it's
very well defined and then
you know deliver that sometime later and
then all of a sudden things are changed
and now they're
you know
wanting something else and then if so
how do you deal with that scenario
yeah and uh i see javier's note fed
luckily over seven years probably still
only two or so also nightmare scenarios
like that um
uh but
it seemed like they were very clear up
front on what they wanted it turns out
that they were not um
and it's a tough situation uh and also
when you're dealing with people or
contractors things happen in life and
we've had
on one occasion a contractor just have
to go pursue a full-time job and in the
middle of a project so you know luckily
you have a bench to handle things like
that but um
yeah i'd say
it really comes down to
um
i keep revisiting the sow and the scope
and saying i i literally will map it out
here's what we that we said the
deliverable was here's what we did
here's the deliverable here's what we
did um here are some things we even did
that were out of scope um you know so
hopefully you can get to a point where
you can justify the end phase by using
that sow now the problem is that we've
had is it actually wasn't that clear slw
is very high level and vague um so then
you run into a scenario where you're
doing a whole bunch of extra work and
you're cutting into margins
um and that sucks so you try to you try
to wrap it up as quickly as possible
with like the minimum viable product or
solution and then
go on to the next phase and honestly try
to make up that
cash in the next phase because
you know there's a lot there's a lot of
work that was done and statement w is
yeah statement of work um
but yeah that's to try to mitigate that
like you could you can always if they're
happy with the end goal regardless of
how it went uh they're gonna pay for
more work you can
i always try to make it up a little bit
in the second phase by either you know
over delivering on things or um just
adding in a few more low hanging fruit
things we know we can do
but that is highly valuable like speed
some optimizations let's parallelize
this thing and give them like a 10x
factor speed boost and that's hugely
valuable for them right even if it
doesn't take us a long time um because i
always try to tell people like they're
paying for your experience just because
it takes you you know a couple days
it would take their team maybe never or
a few weeks or months so you know always
value based price as much as possible
and not just your time because you've
been learning we've been learning this
stuff and researching and doing it for
years and years and years right that's
what they're paying for
um so that might be a long-winded
question but or sorry answered the other
thing i'll mention is
in the beginning we realized one mistake
was that the whole project was scoped by
the the data analysts the users of the
tool
and not the engineers and it turned into
much more of a software engineering
problem
so there's a lot of complexity behind
this tool
that their the analysts were using that
they didn't see it was like a magic
black box to them
um so next time i'd probably make sure
that i
pull in like an engineer and understand
more of the technical requirements of
the thing we were we were essentially
rebuilding
thank you that makes sense
mark didn't mean to jump in on you
um edgar i see you also put a question
to the chat if you want to jump in next
oh absolutely and i i know i apologize
for the typo but um i've struggled over
time to to get a good sense of uh the
developing burn down rate so that i know
when to stop working on what i'm working
because it's getting you know too big in
size or way out of scope
do you have any
wisdom there to share
um are you typically doing like um
hourly is it a fixed price
no no it's uh well i should kind of give
a little background i i work for
internal um stakeholders right so it's
more so
if we think about having two thousand
hours available of people
um and then at some point you know
you're trading off with other projects
or stakeholders because this one project
it's just turning into a frankenstein or
like you know how to kindly stop and say
you know get back the end of the line
now
it turns up
yeah
it is it's tough i i i again try to
always um
get to an end phase that everyone's
agreed upon like
okay we're done with this phase let's
let's stop here
um because we delivered x y and z which
we agreed upon and now there's a bunch
of extra things that are creeping in and
let's let's properly size those and
estimate and start a new phase and if
you feel like well we need to charge
more this time around or we need to pull
in different people or sometimes you
know if we know we don't need a senior
statistician for example phd um we could
charge we charge a lower hourly rate of
course for like a data analyst um
or so if there's no like you know crazy
statistics or machine learning needed
so that's one thing we've done to reduce
cost is we realize oh we don't need like
you know our highest rate card
price we can we can pull in someone else
but still you know still keep the charge
the way it is um
so you know it but it all comes down
again i think to value base like
um
you know if you can say look we've
delivered uh
or if you can actually ask the client
how much they budget they have that's
always an ideal scenario because that
means that they they
have they have budget meaning it's
important
um
it also gives you an idea for
what they value it to be and we've heard
budgets that are sometimes way under
what we can accommodate and we just say
you know that's not for us um sometimes
they're much higher and then we'll give
them options we'll give them tiers like
here's
a bottom tier that's very basic middle
highest and the highest we usually make
kind of ridiculous and hope they don't
pick it sometimes they do right they
want all the bells and whistles and we
say okay we gotta like size up the team
a bit
got it i see i can draw a parallel to
what we still use which is by when you
need it done like when you present it to
your vp or your you know senior most
senior leader and that's like
past that date
we don't continue working kind of thing
so
just having a hard deadline where is
budgetary or time driven thanks yeah no
problem
i see there's a few questions on slido
as well and one was
how do you share your apps with your
clients so they're hidden from your
other clients do you have multiple
servers
we i'm a huge fan of shiny apps that i
owe
so i have probably
10 client apps on shiny apps um
we we
we've been totally good with just the i
think
100 a month package that uh
offers a certain number of hours and
authentication so i just it's a matter
of literally inviting someone via their
work email address to the shiny app
and we've had as much as like probably
30 people on shiny apps and
totally handled everything great
for one app and then another some other
client apps or there's only a few people
but they're power users and they're
constantly using it so shiny apps has
been i haven't needed arcconnect yet but
we do help clients that have their own
arcconnect internally
and then we just work with their
internal our connect team
nice
thank you i see um
another anonymous question was what was
your biggest win for a client that was
data science driven
when as in like i'm assuming i mean like
great like a good success story um
so
that's that's a good question um
i think there's been a couple um one of
them
it doesn't seem as uh
it doesn't sound super cool but there
was a
small pharma company that was
analyzing their clinical trial data and
trying to understand
what's called protocol deviations so
when a
a patient either
disqualifies or doesn't get enrolled and
something went wrong uh in the trial
whether it's like
wrong inclusion criteria like they had
the wrong
cholesterol measurement and they were
accepted or something like that um
they were doing all this super manually
generating reports in excel and
putting together a powerpoint weekly and
it probably took like 20 hours of
multiple people's time
we made a shiny app and turned that into
like pretty much no time at all they
sent us the data it was updated monthly
and they were able to take that to you
know senior management and
clinical trial managers and
make decisions based off that data super
quickly and understand
which clinical trial sites were having
problems what were the biggest problems
and
that is just i think huge versus like
hand crafting all these charts over and
over and over and uh wrangling the data
so
we've had a lot of wins just from moving
someone off excel
into a reproducible like our pipeline
and then displaying all the results in
shiny
um
another similar one i wanted to mention
is
another pharmaceutical company
they do in drug manufacturing there are
a lot of things that can go wrong
and when there's a contaminant or
something
in a batch it can basically
it's millions and millions of dollars of
company loss because they shut down
manufacturing completely until they
identify the problem
and that involves going up and down
stream of these different kind of drug
products and you know two of these
molecules make something and then it
goes into something else and something
else so
um
it was taking a team of like five to ten
people sometimes six months to identify
the problem meaning you're not
manufacturing drugs at that time
we built a shiny app that
built out a kind of d3
directed graph so it enabled one person
to go and type in the drug compound
see everything up and downstream and it
took one person now maybe a week or
several days to identify that problem so
that's you know that's an instance where
you could say this is literally millions
of dollars of savings
from a shiny up right so that to me is
cool and it just shows the power of r
and the ability to really streamline
manual um
processes like that
it's an amazing example
i'm just writing that
writing that time stamp down
that's great um so i see there's a few
others on slido but i see um neil's you
asked the question in the chat too do
you want to jump in
can ask the question if you want to add
context
um how do you deal with
maintenance of projects how much is
included or not included
yup um that's a good one too typically
we'll have a support rate depending on
the person and the skills needed um
and it's we'll either do like a retainer
like you get 10 hours a week five hours
a week of support and
that's an average
and then they'll build hourly on what
they actually do
um or you just agree that it's going to
be an average of certain number of hours
per month and some months is more or
less and you just they just pay that
fixed amount every month
um
typically i think hourly works best
for maintenance just in case things go
really haywire but the biggest thing is
um agreeing on a reasonable sla so
service level agreement so
do you need someone within like two
hours that's we'll charge a lot more for
that um
is it within 72 hours three days 48
hours um
you know that's
that's usually what we try to go for
because i try to i try to work uh with
projects and clients where nothing is an
actual emergency like i'm not a brain
surgeon and uh you know data is fun but
there's usually nothing that's
life-threatening so um making sure you
have reasonable slas and not expected to
like jump out of bed at 2 a.m to fix
something is uh good for your sanity
absolutely
um caitlin i see us a great question in
the chat too if you want to jump in next
all right so
i was just wondering if you could touch
a little bit on your progression through
your data science roles like i was just
looking at your linkedin and i saw an
analyst data scientist a cdo vp and i
was just wondering how did you kind of
know
when it was your time to switch roles or
yeah yeah that's a great question um
so my first job i was learning a ton and
just felt super way in over my head and
i was a like a bioinformatics scientist
or something
and i just i stayed there for about five
years got a few promotions to like start
helping with the
sales of what we were doing um so that
was good but eventually just
wanted to try something else
got basically
a similar role it was kind of a
[Music]
sort um
parallel move and
uh i had a lot less responsibility but
it was a different completely different
industry and um i was learning instead
of i wasn't in bioinformatics anymore
biotech i was learning about distributed
software and databases
um
but i felt like i wasn't being pushed
and i didn't really i wasn't learning
much beyond about the distributed
systems in terms of my data science
skills they were kind of um
stalling
like i found myself supporting
salesforce and helping sales guys you
know do very menial tasks and which is
great like i did get to i started using
tableau there and i got more experience
working with uh business leaders
and then i realized okay i want to try
managing um
and having like a big role at a startup
and so that's what i did next i found a
role at telecom company and was really
brought in to like transform their
entire consulting business into a data
products company and this is a company
that was you know
operating very much as a consultancy but
they had really really valuable data and
a very good use case they were
helping
telecom providers understand
when and why people switched so
back in the day you know
you were all you were going to t-mobile
verizon or sprint and you didn't
everyone had a phone number um
eventually and then it became a poaching
game of like verizon trying to steal
t-mobile's customers and vice versa so
they had all that data because you take
your phone number with you and you
switch um they had your zip code they
had you know a lot of different things
um
so i saw that and i was like well that's
that's valuable and we i could see why
you know verizon will want to know where
high-value t-mobile customers are
located in california
um so anyway that's a lot that's a long
way of saying um
i saw the value in the data i felt like
i could really make a difference there
people were like copy pasting sql
scripts and not saving anything they
were doing and
fat fingers in excel and not able to
reproduce past reports that we had sent
to you know our biggest paying customer
um
so yeah i was brought into and i i
helped hire people and i
i worked my ass off but it was like a
really good great experience and then i
good that's i started to get a little
burnt out and i think that's when i
decided to go back to um
healthcare and a big company
i kind of played the i was a data
scientist and and just took my time to
learn a bunch of things um
and that's when i started consulting on
the side it became much too much i was
working at night and weekends and my
full-time job and i was like it's time
i'm just gonna talk to my boss luckily
my boss was very understanding
and
he we brought them on as a client so now
you know
we were able to have biogen as a client
and um
these different companies that i worked
for so
i think it
it's when you feel like your skills are
stalling or you feel like you're not
being challenged i definitely felt like
okay it's time to make a move and use
everything i learned to like go
make a difference somewhere
it's really interesting thank you yeah
thank you that's really helpful
um lisa i know you you put a question
into the chat too if you want to go next
sure hopefully you can hear me okay um
so it yeah it looks like a lot of or
from what you described a lot of your
big wins are from
you know maybe complex maybe involving
shiny apps uh data summaries and
visualizations and i'm just wondering
um you know how often you find yourself
doing that type of work and
i'm really curious about if
you know do your clients go in thinking
like
oh they're going to make us
a complex data vis or do they go in
thinking we need ai and machine learning
and you are kind of like
you know
pulling them back a little
yes yes yes so like everything uh
basically i would i always tell people i
would say we really only do
machine learning statistical modeling
maybe 20 of the time
um
a lot of work we do is uh like you said
data summaries visualization
automating manual processes and moving
them out of excel a lot of shiny
shiny development work
um
i could give an example about the
department of defense they had budget
for a big ai machine learning effort
we did actually end up doing some pretty
cool machine learning for them um
but like you said a lot of companies
think they need machine learning or ai
and they they really don't like they
just need some summary statistics uh and
we we can talk them off the ledge with
that by usually just showing them what
can be done and then
they they see it and they're they're
happy um they realize okay that maybe
that was
that maybe that's down the road
um but for the department of defense
they had an inventory problem so
every time anything is purchased in the
in the army anything from batteries to
laptops to apache helicopter parts it's
all entered into a database and it's
entered pretty much manually on the
field from a laptop so there's a lot of
typos and fat fingering
zeros that are o's ones that are l's
um
and we're talking like 1.2
i want to say was billion records or
something
um so there's no easy way to go in and
just you know
fuzzy match or de-duplicate
so if the army doesn't know what's
readily on hand in their inventory how
can they be you know
ready for certain situations so we were
about in to do that um
did some really cool
we used some genetic algorithms i don't
remember off the top i had exactly which
ones but ways of comparing different
fields um
and then quantifying things like
the keyboard distance from different
keys common typos
and then using levensheen distance for
fuzzy matching and and combining all
these things into a very
custom
machine learning solution for them and
then using a shiny app to expose the
results so we found
you know a whole bunch of items that
were
clustered together because they were
very similar but they were duplicates
and so then we worked on scaling that
with them and helping them find all
those um
now the ai part we kept explaining them
that's way off in the distance right you
have to do the machine learning first
have a human in the loop
um that's what the shiny app did it
helps us then visualize the results and
then agree with them and say this is re
this is right this is not
and that
we kept explaining to them like that
builds up your training set so
have someone come in you know there is
manual work involved like this isn't a
magic button where a robot comes in uh
and just does it all so
i think it's the hump between machine
learning and ai that's that's really
complicated because there's no way you
turn on a switch and just let the
machine automatically do this stuff
especially if it's like very important
let's say healthcare related data
so yeah you're totally right and we
talked them off the ledge and i wouldn't
say that we've ever done artificial
intelligence yet at this point we've
done a lot of machine learning but
getting to the ai part is a lot of i
think human involved uh work
to get there
until you feel comfortable enough
turning that switch and letting letting
the machines take over
thank you that's a really cool example
uh let me see there's a few other
questions that were on slido earlier i
wanted to make sure i get to as well and
both were around dealing with sensitive
data
do you have experience working with
clients who manage sensitive health data
are there hipaa compliant blueprints out
there for hosting shiny apps
oh very good question we have a lot and
we've struggled in the past with um you
know
especially with um
what's uh the drug manufacturing work
we're doing um i had to do some research
on making sure it was all
uh
i can't remember the word no it's not it
will fda there you know there's fda
um
regulations and there's all kinds of
things you have to comply with but um
for the most part we haven't you know
run into any issues where we just
literally can't do something
um
people are typically
trustworthy now or trusting of aws and
they have hippa compliant um
clusters there's also a gov gov cloud
so we use that for the dod
luckily in the data we're working with
nothing was classified so that helped i
didn't need like security clearance
um but yeah it's uh
i think there's there's a lot of stuff
out there now to support it r can be
validated in a clinical environment as
well and usually it involves just
writing proper unit tests and making
sure things are reproducible um so
we've had the discussions but it's never
been like a show stopper and usually it
comes down to oh we need everything in
our cloud so they have their own
rconnect and it's behind their vpn and
firewall
but yeah the aws hipaa clusters we've
we've used i actually don't know though
with shiny apps um
i haven't run into that situation yet
where it's been
a problem
but i'd be curious like definitely feel
free to follow up with me after too
um
i think rachel you might share my
twitter or something at the end so
people can reach out
definitely yeah and i think the other
question touches upon this too because
it was asking around shiny apps i o
isn't that hosted by our studio
so what about the sensitive data but i
think you just answered
as well
yeah i typically just tell clients like
look aws is gonna be more secure
probably than you know what what you've
got on site but it really depends um
so uh i think it's becoming more and
more people are becoming more and more
trusting of the cloud so that helps
thank you
um
javier c you put a question to the chat
a bit ago as well if you want to jump in
yeah thanks it touches on
shinyapps.i o as well
just about package management
um
[Music]
do you are you building
project specific packages or packages
that contain you know
modules or
functions that you're reusing a lot and
if so
have you had
like how are you deploying that to shiny
apps
yeah um
so we actually most recently we started
using gollum which is the
makes like production grade shiny
applications and gives you a whole bunch
of stuff like testing and
documentation um
but
we didn't have a problem we built our
own package that did some
custom d3 visualization for a pharma
company
um
and we didn't deploy on shiny apps but
we did deploy they deployed it
internally to their rconnect server um
and there were no problems there so i
don't i haven't had any issues
yet or i haven't deployed my own package
to shiny apps um
but
we using gollum we had no problems uh
deploying our own package to
our connect so i don't know if that
answers it but it does yeah that's
awesome thanks yeah
awesome uh tiffany i see you just put a
question in the chat you want to jump in
hi
hi um yeah i just was wondering if you
do most of your work remotely
um or if you ever get to visit the
companies that you work with
and
if you
get to visit do you find there's a lot
of value seeing where that data is
generated um like for example
if you go visit a lab and you get to
witness how the
scientists are entering their data maybe
that gives you some greater insights on
the how to um generate your apps to
capture that and help them yeah yeah
that's an awesome question um
well during pandemic of course was all
remote uh but yeah we're a remote based
company um however yeah i used to go
into client sites probably a few at
least a few times a week um
and
oftentimes
yeah i do think it's helpful
not only can you understand like how the
data is being generated sometimes but
understanding the politics of situations
too where people work with the you know
how they work together how often they're
talking there's just a lot of things you
can pick up on
when you are on site
um
and of course you know
whiteboarding things is really nice but
one example i can think of that was
pretty cool was
we work for
a healthcare devices company that
creates the
they manufacture the rapid blood testing
kits in hospitals so
when you're at if you're at a hospital
hopefully you're not um
you get your blood drawn and they have
the results very rapidly that's the
company that that
we do work for and their problem was
that they had all this um these faulty
devices going out into the field at
times right make things happen with
hardware fails um
but there's a ton of sensor data coming
off of those machines
and so we were brought in to do some
anomaly detection identify those
some spikes and particular proteins or
problems before that hardware that blood
testing machine gets out into the fields
at the various hospitals and i got to
tour like that lab and it was a massive
you know
massive uh place with just all these
machines and they showed me where the
data's coming off of and how it gets you
know put into a database and i think
just having that contextual
knowledge and and meeting with the
people you're working with is invaluable
and um i was definitely a person that
did not enjoy going to an office every
single day but i i really loved being
able to go to different client sites you
know a few times a week
so i do miss it after this pandemic now
i i think i'll appreciate it even more
but um
yeah it's super valuable um one of our
clients is opening a drug manufacturing
plant in switzerland so of course i'm
trying to go there
that's great i love how relaxed pork
chop is back there
he doesn't earn his keeper on here he
needs to work a little harder
he's our chief security officer
um i was curious daniel what what has
been the hardest thing about starting
your own company
hardest thing
um
well there's been challenges the first
ever when i when i gave my two weeks um
there's obviously a huge panic like wow
the checks are gonna stop coming in
yeah get a job porcha
and um you know there's that panic that
sets in like okay this is really like
all up to me now right um now if you
have a spouse of course that helps like
i had health insurance because i was
able to go on my wife's uh insurance and
um
obviously that helps and i saved a bunch
of money before making the so i had an
emergency fund and all that but uh
that's scary that's the i would say
that's the hardest part is really just
making the leap but
two weeks into it like i never looked
back i was like this is it this is
awesome it's working out
um and you just gotta like keep going
and it's nice to know it's all kind of
on you and you can't really blame other
people now if things fail or
um
you know
there's always people involved but it's
nice to know that you're kind of in
charge of
if you want to make more money one year
you work a lot more if you don't care
then and you're okay then that's fine
and i'm definitely a person
i'm enjoying work-life balance a lot
more now so i try not to overload myself
um
but in consulting it's also waves like
it totally
always happens that suddenly we have
like 10 leads come in and sometimes i
have a hard time saying no because it's
such an interesting project and i want
to work with these people
um so you know we'll i'll pull in more
consultants to help if i need to
so that stuff and then also not having
stuff like this which is that's why i'm
so glad that you do these hangouts um
not interact with people every day in an
office obviously
sometimes it's nice to just talk to
other data nerds so i have some friends
that i talk to also consult and will
kind of commiserate about problems or
ask for advice
and the other thing i did was i started
a slack community of data scientists so
when i went out on my own i knew i
wanted to keep in touch with all these
awesome people that i met throughout the
years whether at conferences or at jobs
college friends even and so i invited
them to a slack community it's kind of
grown organically over the years
it's called friendly tech space and you
can feel free to message me if you'd
like an invite but it's very much for
networking it's a private space people
talk about career development and
our problems and python and and then
there's you know random
channels too so that's one thing i did
to mitigate that problem as well to kind
of like keep my skills sharp and keep in
touch with people
nice thank you
i was just looking in the friendly tech
space slack too
yeah
sorry are you having in-person events
again with it not yet no we've done
virtual tech talks we have people
sometimes give a talk and um
but we haven't done an in-person event
since boston and before the pandemic and
now that i'm in florida i don't know i
don't know how many people are down here
but uh maybe we'll plan one for up north
or something soon or try to get people
at um our studio conf together but uh
yeah sometimes i'm not as active in
there either because i'm just
busy with client work but uh it's
awesome to have people just like helping
each other in there and talking about
questions together
definitely
libby i see you had a question in the
chat too
yeah um she kind of actually answered it
telling you a little bit you were like
you mentioned um that there were some
projects where you were approached and
you felt like it was too much
and you needed to
take on more people to help with it um
are there
any people who have you know approached
you with things that you felt like your
team just couldn't solve like
this isn't worth it
yeah yeah for sure um
i'd say on you know we have
we're gaining on the kind of devops
software engineering architecture side
of things but we've started to realize
that's not really what we want to do or
what we're
good at and um i mean we're good at it
enough but like it's not or our sweet
spot right it's not our bread of butter
um we can do it but i number one i
prefer to do the analysis um
i prefer to do the shiny development and
things like that so we've accepted
projects like that we've done it and
gotten through it and done a good job
and delivered but there's times where i
just felt like we you know we can do
better work elsewhere um
so yeah like
exactly figuring out your boundaries not
saying yes to everything i've learned
that over the years in the beginning
you're hungry right you're saying yes to
everything you're like i need to pay the
bills and eat and
eventually you can pick and choose
things and i think we're really starting
to hone in now on
a lot of shiny work we're really
focusing there um
where we excel is like
helping business the business answer
questions with data and under
tying tying that gap um
you know there's just such a skills gap
between people that are they can live in
excel and do so much stuff there but
then you know
that lift going to something like our
python is just
you can you're like a superstar and you
can you can do so much so fast and
people have asked me at jobs they come
over to my desktop how did you generate
that plot so fast so i'm like r g plot
and then they become like a believer too
um
so anyway yeah i think that we're
starting to kind of focus a lot more on
what we're really good at and it took
you know it's been seven years so it
takes time
i love those examples of things being so
much faster with with arm and like
showing how how you can do it but i'm
curious if there's someone who's
listening and who's
like the only our user at their company
and they're trying to like get people on
board
yeah that's funny a lot of times
i see lisa's waiting
yes bless gigi but i think shiny is
always the
the game changer people see that and
they're like oh you know
i'd love to hear from someone else like
how you evangelize r what you've done
being like the solo r person
i'm sorry are you gonna say something no
go ahead go ahead lisa please
um i mean i'm very new to my job but um
i think there's still a sense that like
r is this
statistical programming language which
it is
but
you know i think the way to pull things
in is actually with more like the
parameterized reporting and eventually
stuff like shiny
i need a lot more tooling set up to be
able to like do that nicely but
you know i don't think at least not
people in my organization they don't
think like oh r is great for making
reproducible reports and i'm like
no it's really good at that
yeah so just showing off some of that
stuff that people don't know about
yeah and i think that's it we've taught
a lot of r too and one thing that makes
people kind of get it is um we do this
exercise where you give half the class
and a
task to do an excel and half the class
does it in r and then we just change a
parameter we say okay now do the same
thing but for like this baseball player
instead of this one and the rsi is done
in like two seconds and they just change
one thing at the top of the script the
excel people are like going to get the
data again and like you know having to
wrangle it and do things and um it
really gets people i think to like oh i
get what scripting is now and why it's
like fast and reproducible
that's such a good idea
um javier i know you were about to jump
in too
no i i mean
lisa kind of took the words out of my
mouth so
same kind of thing um
i partner a lot with
i mean i used to be in finance back in
the day so i i end up partnering often
with our finance
teams and um
they generally see the value
let's say right away because they
understand the limitations of excel or
you know something like excel that they
might be using um
and when they realize that
you know you could very easily use like
tighter for pivoting longer pivoting you
know wide but
instead of having like a million row cap
or
five million row cap they could do this
with you know a billion rows um
they're always super impressed and then
just like all the manual work that they
have to do on a
monthly basis for for month end close or
quarter end
um
seeing how you can automate a lot of
that to just
take out most of the
manual um manual work i think impresses
a lot and then just like like shiny apps
like everyone's saying or you know rmd
presentations that are just knitted to
html or websites like jarring on
websites like these are things that
you know if you're comfortable with r
and r d like
jumping to those websites is
pretty easy and then seeing how you can
automate all the elements within those
websites also impresses people
so
all right yeah and and one thing we were
able to do in a shiny app was um i was
just gonna say officer yeah um
they were again making manual uh
powerpoints and charts and anytime i see
that i see us in so many companies
they're just like
copied like excel copy paste and like oh
it's just
and
we streamline it and we put it either in
a shiny app so all the sequel's done for
you you pick a filter whatever it is um
yeah and officer lets you literally
download a
powerpoint deck with svg uh graphics by
the way so you can edit the titles and
the charts and everything it's just that
like people see and they're like their
mind is blown because it takes them you
know
days to put these powerpoints together
i was just sharing libby's talk on uh
officer nice
um someone sent a question for me to ask
and it was
do you ever use plumber when you deliver
a shiny app to a customer
i have not actually i know it's for apis
but i have not used it yet probably on
my list
as soon as we have another use case for
it though
awesome i want to make sure there
weren't questions that i missed through
slido or through the chat earlier
so just want to remind everyone if you
want to raise your hand on zoom feel
free to as well
i was asking people this a lot in the
beginning when we started these but are
there certain resources or podcasts or
books that you'd recommend to us all
um
yeah there's so much good stuff out
there now i i don't i don't know if um
jesse most of pack is is doing her live
twitch coding anymore but she
uh is on twitter i don't know if you can
link her twitter handle maybe but she
was like learning shiny and in real time
twitch streaming it and people could
come in and ask questions and um she's
always a good resource because she was
actually a high school teacher
and turned non-profit data scientist so
um
she's just like a huge she's like my
resource when i need to go to where do i
find things learn about and then of
course you know r4ds uh hadley and um
anything i i've used our studio
documentation like
beyond for shiny just
it's a great resource and there's good
videos there um
and then the what's uh hugo's podcast is
he still doing that
that's usually a good one
i'm not sure what the name
yeah he'd start doing this one separate
from from data datacamp i know that
we don't use datacamp anymore
you can um i can look it up yeah but the
gradient oh that's right some of them in
the chat too and feel free if everyone
else has others feel free to share too
and stack overflow 60 of my code yes
i do a lot there's a lot of that um
there's so many i've been using r for
what's 2017 years is that it that's
ridiculous and i google so many things
so i can't tell you how many times i
copy paste how to rotate
axes in ggplot every time
okay i see libby you asked another
question too and i'm really curious
about this as well as i think about
speaking at the r studio conference so
do you want to ask that one
sure um shameless plug for the podcast
that i'm developing which is kind of all
about this is um
imposter syndrome mitigation i feel like
there's a really big
veil of mystery that's like drawn over
data science jobs because we maybe don't
speak to each other about what we do on
a daily basis like i don't know what all
these other people do they must be doing
something that's so much more complex
than what i know how to do i must be
terrible and not a very good data
scientist um so have you ever dealt with
imposter syndrome and
you know what did that feel like for you
yeah i think
if anyone has an experience that they're
doing something wrong
like
uh because i mean there's so many
talented people out there and like you
know at my first job especially like i
said it was all like phd
level statisticians from cornell and
um
i just
you know i'd be in three hour long
conversations about them debating the
use of a various pro certain prior for
bayesian
algorithm and anyway i um
yeah of course and i think uh
what you have to realize too is what
people are putting out there and people
on twitter that's you know oftentimes
are focused very much on one thing or
it's their entire career and their job
is based around it and
um
i've learned like i don't have to be the
best at any one thing
but i can focus on what i am good at and
if that's uh
helping you know
with the technical communication between
the business and the tech people then
i'll focus there like i don't want to be
the best coder i can bring in someone
that i know is a d3 wizard or i can
bring in someone that i know is great at
optimizing code
i've always felt like i know enough to
be dangerous um
but yeah i think everyone deals with it
and
at the end of the day you know there's
way too much to know to absolutely feel
like you're an expert at almost anything
uh
like i i when i do time series
forecasting i remember for a client it's
i use packages are available i
i try to you know
consult with with
if i need to consult with a statistician
that i'm one of my good friends i trust
i will um but there are people that
spend their entire lives like
researching just one segment of time
series forecasting right
so um yeah just keep learning and it's
possible to know it all and and
remember to keep the confidence that you
should have because
if you're using r at all you're already
way ahead of you know most of the
population
yes job and job requirements are
terrible actually i have a talk about
this entire topic and not to like
shamelessly self plug but i i do kind of
go off on a data science
job descriptions so i'll try to link
that real quick it was from strata in
new york uh a while back
so i will link the
talks
but yeah i kind of
i go there's all these crazy venn
diagrams of data science skills required
and uh it's all about that
i know an hour goes by super quickly so
i just wanted to check if you have a
hard stop or if you have a few more
minutes
i have a few minutes okay cool
um i see parth you asked the question in
the chat do you want to jump in live
um maybe you don't have a microphone um
yes so i can ask it is shiny proxy a
good alternative to shiny server pro
does anyone have experience
with shiny proxy that's the question
i don't so i can't speak to it either
but
i i i remember using it like once way
back when i was trying to get
authentication for free and it was uh
yeah it ended up being um
we just ended up going with uh shiny
surfer pro i think and now we just use
shiny ups
someone probably has used it though and
i know i've heard good things about it
and tiffany i see you asked the question
about conference do you want to jump in
yeah i'm um so i'm currently a student
trying to get my masters and
i'm
learning art in our studio and kind of i
think at the beginning stages and i saw
that there was like some workshops that
the conference offers and i feel like
the intro one be
matched to me
um but i just didn't know if there was
it would be an overwhelming experience
for someone in my position or if i would
have like some value from it
i am super biased so not the best person
to answer this question but would
absolutely love for you to join us and
we'd love to meet you there too and
get to all hang out in person but yeah
i'll let other people answer too
definitely go to it it is i don't work
for our studio and it is the best
conference i've ever been to like
there is at least one thing every
section session that i want to be at
usually for
so
um and as someone who's new um you will
find something for you as well
yeah
i i also definitely recommend going it
was
the best conference i have also been to
um and just
the networking alone and the people you
get to meet for sure is worth it like i
met a few people that now i've worked
with after after the fact
and learned a lot from
absolutely yeah and if anybody is going
or anyone is thinking about going and
i know we all haven't been in person in
a really long time and so it might be
like nerve-wracking too
um
so would love to like
i'll chat about it ahead of time so we
know we have a group of friends there
too so feel free to always reach out on
linkedin too and let me know
and i see tatsu's putting in some
recommendations for the workshops too
there are a lot of awesome workshops as
well
awesome well thank you so much tanya for
sharing your experience with us and
just answering all our questions and
thank you all for the questions too that
was fun yeah well this is great thank
you for having me the questions are
awesome and i could talk about this
stuff all day so i didn't even know
about this event for some reason so i'm
gonna probably try to join on thursdays
now when i can awesome we'd love to have
you here
cool
bye everybody
you